und jetzt kann ich euch sagen was diese
große aktion sein wird die in den
nächsten wochen kommen wird und zwar
services kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute spielen wir eine
runde jump league ganz klassisch und ich
werde euch heute mal erzählen wie es für
mich mit dem burger bettet weitergeht da
stehen nämlich einige richtig richtig
krasse sachen an von denen ich heute
erzählen möchte dazu aber später mehr so
als aller erstes mal
wie ist es für mich jetzt verlaufen ihr
wisst ja am 18 april war das glaube ich
war das event in münchen
da habe ich glücklicherweise den winter
bin ich unter die besten vier eingezogen
von den 16 die da waren
danke schön nochmal alle die mich da im
voting anfangs unterstützt haben
es war echt cool es ist als habe sich so
viele coole sachen raus ergeben das kann
ich euch teilweise gar nicht alles
erzählen aber es ist richtig richtig
nice weit mehr als burger battle hat
sich daraus entwickelt echt echt doof
kann ich es mal kurz schaffen hier danke
hier auch er ok oh holy genau 18 der
fürther war das burger natürlich erzählt
chronologisch für euch da sind wir unter
den besten vier eingezogen
an dem tag habe so mega viele interviews
die da gehalten wurden ich wollte die
ganze zeit gefragt fotografiert richtig
ungewöhnlich das war echt komisch aber
okay haben wir damit gemacht natürlich
auch ein interview mit joyce und so die
waren ja auch da die moderatorin
das war ganz witzig sodann kam dann die
bestehe dann die nachricht dass ich da
ja sagen geschafft haben oder die besten
vier ich mich natürlich übels gefreut
ohne ja ich dann war ich lange lange im
unklaren darüber wie es jetzt weitergeht
waren mein burger kommt und so aber ich
hab jetzt neue infos erhalten und die
will ich euch heute mal berichten und
infos mit euch teilen so während ich
hier durch die gegend brausen glaube ich
bin's niveau also das erste ist dass am
29.6 der essen sind es in die läden
kommt am 29 06
die burger hinlegen ich denke mal dass
alle auf einen schlag in die läden
kommen also dass mein schiff mit dabei
ist wenn am 29 06 und die bürger starten
es könnte aber auch sein dass jetzt nur
zwei staaten und der essener dass es
später kommt
ich vermute aber dass sie alle auf einen
schlag in die läden kommen wären also 29
sechster das datum könnt ihr euch
markieren dann gibt es den und ich werde
wahrscheinlich auch noch mal in den
laden gehen kann und wie job machen wie
ich den fuß oder so ich hab auch wenig
gesagt dass ich ihn noch in essen sind
es ausgeben und so vielen leuten die
mich da unterstützt haben
auf dem chip ist für eine fluglinie
theorien transportieren oh ja so das war
das 19 6 als die erste info dann ich
weiß ich bin ich male den den knaller
für den rest auf das wird wahrscheinlich
im laufe hallo wie solche lang ihr
können in die kiste geh wach als ob da
lange nicht sein ernst
ok fachgebiet alter das ist ricky dann
ist wird es eine ins eine homestory
geben nennt sich das das wird mit
mcdonald's gedrehten home story ist so
was wie ja ich werde glaube ich hier zu
hause okay ich es aber inzwischen
geöffnet hier zu hause besucht und
mcdonald's berichtet dann so ein
bisschen über mich wie ich so
privatleben ok danke checkpoint wie ich
hier wohne ich muss mal schauen dass sie
dann nicht verplappern wo ich wohne
das müssen wir irgendwie hinkriegen aber
das wird auf jeden fall gedreht werden
habe ich heute die info bekommen so eine
hohe also eine homestory alsfeld
irgendwie keine ahnung der letzte von
dem ich gehört habe dass eine homestory
über ihn gedreht wurde bavaro fahrgäste
griechische finanzminister so also als
wenn ich so eine über kasse personen des
öffentlichen lebens richtig komisch
dankeschön gleich zu schaffen
ich bin auch wieder ganz gut auf platz
zwei also da passieren richtig richtig
gute dinge ich habe ja auch über diesem
dieses mcdonald's event dann noch einen
anderen quasi ein geschäftspartner
kennen gelernt mit dem ich jetzt dinge
mache ja vielleicht bei max und luca
gesehen dass wir beim mai deals waren so
also bei dies ist dieser partner richtig
richtig coole leute die haben wie 40
drohnen im büro sind sohn sind so
chillige nutzer und dann bei uns eine
richtig richtig richtig geiles konzept
ausgedacht dadurch auch mal
drauf freuen das wird echt nice so wie
ich jetzt hier weiter ich glaub schon
alles klar
jojo alter trick und dann hier rüber
okay da ist es schwierig so ich würde
sagen wir warten noch bis zum deathmatch
bevor ich dann die die bombe drop.io man
isst du bist so als ob jetzt alles von
vorne machen muss egal das und das ist
normal angeblich das ist richtig tricky
das ding ja so das wird passieren dann
wird es auch noch in einem restaurant
ein event geben leute also in irgend
einem restaurant in deutschland wird
irgendwie ein event mit mir veranstaltet
wo ich dann da hingehe und der essen
seite ist da irgendwie eingeweiht wird
oder so ich glaube das ist die idee
dabei alter schwede die sprünge sehr
richtig happig holy [ __ ] is ok
checkpoint jetzt das ja erst hast dich
auch dieses modul dass es richtig crazy
ich glaub ich habe die kiste übersehen
kann das sein
die zeit war doch gerade eben schon bei
234 oder bin ich blind
ich schwöre gerade eben schon 234 oder
230 oder so die wurde im juli startet
aber ich sehe was ich mache ich soll ich
ich weiß nein der unentschlossene auf
jeden fall müssen wir erst mal drüber
jumpen eins nach dem andern muss ich
prioritäten setzen im leben so also es
wird noch so ein event in einem
restaurant irgendwo in deutschland geben
da weiß ich auch noch nicht viel ich
habe übrigens auch in den letzten tagen
ist die infos bekommen wie es jetzt
weiter geht also ich glaube die sind da
auch relativ wie soll man sagen hier
unkoordiniert aber nicht im negativen
sinne sondern die haben noch nicht zu
den masterplan fahrt ging steht das ist
so richtig richtig richtig schwierig da
die ecke zu kommen schreibt mir mal die
kommentare wichtig ein sprung hier
gleich schaffen kann ich zeig dir mama
wartet wartet den nicht
das weiß ich aber den hier der ist er
richtig crazy alter okay das budget aber
direkt so und jetzt glaubt hier rüber
was soll ich nicht tun
hey was soll ich nicht tun er schreibt
us nicht aber was nicht tun
oh gott ist ich hoffe ich verpackte
nicht janacek und ich war noch nie so
weit ich habe glaube ich ich würde ich
habe noch nie
diese space bio mir geschafft dass das
erste mal dass das pack in meinem ganzen
leben live auf krass eltern dann auch
noch in der aufnahme jiji na ja ich sag
jetzt schon mal so viele leute es wird
auch noch eine richtig richtig krasse
aktion geben und zwar in einem sehr sehr
beliebten medium sagen wir mal in einem
sehr beliebten medium da werde ich
wahrscheinlich eine menge leute sehen
eine ganze menge leute und da haben wir
auch schon ein paar gesagt ja da muss
irgendwie sagen ey sk harmoniert mich
auf youtube oder so youtube-channel
müssen mal schauen vielleicht kann ich
das irgendwie einbauen aber muss so
mancher es wird auf jeden fall stick
alter okay die sind die brust erhalten
die die garde heftige attacken sind aber
ich hänge gehört auch ein bisschen auf
jeden fall leute die gesamte geschichte
ist einfach mega es für mich also ich
hab einfach richtig richtig viel spaß
gehabt dabei bisher und es wird noch so
viel cool ist da passieren ist einfach
geil stellt mal vor ich hätte damals
nicht gesagt ich mache jetzt mit
bamberger battle der wenn wir so viel
entgang und ist jetzt wie gesagt die
ganze sache ist übrigens kein poker face
mit oder sollen das ist wirklich
wirklich geile sache und ich habe
persönlich sehr viel spaß dran aber
leute werden jetzt das deathmatch
erreicht und jetzt kann ich euch sagen
was diese große aktion sein wird die in
den nächsten wochen kommen wird und zwar
wird ein tv-spot gedreht werden
und das finde ich richtig krass stelle
ich mir vor ich bin ein im fernsehen
vortrag wie krank ist das denn einfach
irgendwie ein tv-spot wo ich dann kälter
wird es los mit dem wo ich mein burger
präsentiere oder so und ich war übrigens
auch im rahmen der video das schon mal
im fernsehen
da gab es so einem tag folge da bin ich
auch kurz darauf ganz witzig zur commerz
bis nur noch drauf da es aber dann mal
richtig im fernsehen irgend einem
werbespot und das wird in irgendeiner
großstadt in deutschland gedreht ich
weiß noch nicht genau wo alles sieht auf
jeden fall alles cultra cool alter traum
wie die natur nicht schlagen kann
übertreibt man nicht ein leben junger
herkommer gucke ich das an geständig
typen nicht schlagen
jannis läpple leben gesehen seltsam
egal was alles noch sehr schön so angl
action angel action schreibt man die
kommentare was ihr davon haltet das dass
es dann wahrscheinlich ist im fernsehen
findet ihr es so der schön oder was
haltet ihr davon ich finde mich ich
finds echt krass dass das heftige ist
halt das ist eigentlich immer im leben
so man kann leistet corporate place mit
alle drei saugut gemacht direkt unter
micha rhein gesprungen bin
es ist oft im leben so dass man einfach
nicht abschätzen kann wo es hingeht wenn
man sich auf irgendwas einlässt man weiß
halt nie wo die reise hingeht etwas
anders bringt das ist die sache das
merke ich jetzt wieder wäre ich hätte am
anfang nie gedacht dass ich irgendwie
mal das ding überhaupt gewinnen würde
geschweige denn dass da irgendwie so
coole sachen daraus entstehen würden
dass ich dann wie im fernsehen sein
würde oder so das ist echt es ist echt
spannend also ich glaube die lassen die
man daraus ziehen kann oder die
erkenntnis ist dass man sich einfach auf
möglich viele dinge einlassen sollte im
leben die möglichen dinge ausprobieren
weil man halt nie sagen kann ja okay das
ist das und daraus passiert dann das
hier was wir für den hier passiert ist
dass er stirbt welt mit ja okay da hat
aber auch gar nichts interessantes kann
man hier einmal zwei leben irgendwo
suppanz swg schels geht mir gut
das war die idee finde ich das an man
kann die typen nicht hätten alter was
ist mit dem
das ist mit diesem jugend ich kann
einfach nicht hätten würden wir viele
einfach noch leben
mister spex ruhig mal da drüben in einen
ganoven schon geholt
okay da drohte damit rote für die guten
games ja ich bin mal gespannt was ihr
davon haltet
wie gesagt schreibt das gerne in die
kommentare wie seht ihr die ganze
geschichte für mich das halt einfach
davon
der boys noize am wien 17 17
kühlflüssigkeit den klarspüler und ja
jetzt mal gucken ob ich jetzt schlagen
kann
was dir fehlt für hits gilt alles was er
mir für hits gibt habt ihr das gesehen
what the [ __ ] aber ggf
da konnte man nichts machen so krass
alter d.red fucking range auf jeden fall
leute ich will im zeitdruck tatsächlich
ich gehe jetzt gleich direkt weiter zum
tränen ich hab euch einfach mal kurz
erzählt was da das so ansteht wie gesagt
ich bin gespannt auf eure meinung las
gerne daumen nach oben da wir sehen uns
morgen wieder wahrscheinlich kam heute
um erfolge geht also checkt ihm ab